ah bonjour alors une petite fille
apparemment dans un asile génial oh la
vache vous faire l'injection de quelque
chose c'est la moustache qui te donne tu
regardes dieu glauque relâchement forêt
jetage la moustache
oh la vache
qu'est-ce qui fait exception mais qu'est
ce qu'ils font ok je crois que donc déjà
c'est un mec cas de cannes c'est plutôt
étrange et m'ont fait une injection de
quelque chose voilà voilà
bienvenue dans blackwell asie l'uimm un
jeu complètement effrayant on va essayer
de se plonger dans l'histoire
alors donc ça c'est les contrôles nanana
hockey à temps plein il y avait de quoi
non mon tant pis donc je dois je peux ce
que je me réveille et je suis
complètement déchiré à cause de cette
seringue c'est ça exactement ça à
londres est bien fait d'accord ok alors
je peux courir wyatt des médocs et tout
mais sûrement une belle pleine lune
qu'on peut voir dans les nuages
bon on y voit c'est parti alors on va se
marrer ou cette porte là
ok donc juste le bruit la preuve tu fais
un pays fait super peur presley faiseur
to open the door en champions parce
qu'il faut faire
nerfs dans un couloir non donc c'est pas
là ok la cua chiffre tout rond
ok donc je pense qu'on va devoir essayer
de s'enfuir alors pour sandor locked
karkwa là dedans
hyde watts [ __ ] une espèce de machine
de lobotomisation [ __ ] c'est à mais
j'aime ce que ces trois ans elle est de
plus en plus traitement oh la vache
vieux monde est inquiet qu'est ce qu'on
doit faire
alors presse étaient tous nick you might
laisse l'eau soignent ou smic alors fait
moins de bruit quand on marche ok
d'accord cette porte cette porte cette
porte est fermée
cette porte peut-être alors
d'accord tchad mais pourquoi tout est
géométriquement modifié alors ok donc là
on se cache au [ __ ] mais c'est super
glauque comme jeu on est d'accord
space when you're so right wing hockey
assez sa respiration à dilma rousseff
vous avez vous tendance ok donc ça en
gros c'est d'accord très bien bon c'est
petit tuto du début du jeu absolument
c'est quoi ça ah ah ah ouais a même moi
ça m'a défoncé les yeux je me cache je
m'en vais d'ici ce qu'elle cherche mais
elle veut s'enfuir de l'asie living d'or
open alors est-ce que a donc là je pense
qu'on veut se cacher là dessous ok
d'accord donc tout ce qu'ils ont versé
pour se cacher là aussi
ok très bien d'accord mais jusque là pas
de raison de se cacher en moins qui est
d'aider des fantômes et des monstres
presse qu on ne t'oublie nous ça c'est
pour se pencher alors que ça c'est fermé
on a va devoir se pencher
y'a le gardien ferme ta gueule non
johnny cash
c'est bon voilà alors qu'est ce que
c'est que ce jeu là mais ça se passe mal
je suis trop grillé mais qui va arriver
il va faire mais qui es tu sûr le bureau
pourquoi es tu là qu'est ce qu'est ce
que tu fais là bon à mes rien monsieur
je vois là moi je suis dans cet asus que
j'aime me mettre sous des bureaux un bon
pas seulement je pensais qu'on peut y
aller j'ai tellement peur
kaka korac
la personne pourquoi pourquoi là haut
laissez-moi - nallet ok qu'est ce qu'on
fait on peut passer par là absolument
pas et bien en ce moment à nous la
liberté
enfin pour 2 m des libertés
d'accord bon très bien j'arrive what the
fuck
pourquoi c'est le décor a changé je je
je délire pas un
rassurez moi sommes en fait c'est un
[ __ ] de annoncé un sale labyrinthe
d'accord ou jour labyrinth un corbeau
morts
non et aux tâches à marmande à l'est
mais [ __ ] mais c'est incroyable ce jeu
jusqu'au bout
c'est quoi ce oui oui des petits bruits
la dcri je m'en vais dans des cages en
train de passer je sens des bouffées de
chaleur bonsoir l'ambiance de dingue de
quoi le truc partout pour se cacher on
voyait ça j'ai eu peur j'ai peur d'une
grippe a les reprends ton souffle
[ __ ] glen un espèce d'asile deux
psychopathes mental
bonjour une tête
non bon je suppose que enfin en fait
c'est un labyrinthe voilà c'est bon j'ai
compris le délire du jeu c'est un [ __ ]
de labyrinthe il ya un gardien il ya une
sortie et voilà bon alors qu'est-ce
qu'on fait ça ces fermes et déjà c'est
super cool bon on peut on va passer par
cette porte à gauche niais watts
asim tombe dessus euh je fais un
cocktail molotov mois avec du feu qu'est
ce qu'on fait là [ __ ] ça
assis là à gauche n'est ce pas qu'il a
la gauche
soulignons aussi vient ohlala
j'entendais pas c'est bon un peu très
rassurant mais ça c'est comme quand tu
traverses dans la rue il ya le feu le
feu et les rouges puis tu as tandis que
tu dis bon j'ai peut-être y aller mais
là tu dis maintenant s'ils passent au
vert pendant que je passe donc tu rates
en 10 secondes puis tu dis non mais là
ça fait vingt secondes
alors je vais y aller mais vu que t'as
tendu 20 secondes j'ai encore plus de
chance que fait passe rien donc qui va
encore pas tu t'attendais fois deux
minutes comme ça là ça va être pareil
passage le jeu s'emballe à l'autre on
bat les couilles
ah ah
mais on est où là
sa ferme et la basse et le couloir à
gauche tara mais ces labyrinthes là j'ai
toujours détesté ça j'en avais dans
adibou là encore je t en c'était pas des
salles pas de raz la [ __ ] ya des vieux
pas de rater un mois
bonjour non je ne suis pas gagné c'est
faux
on va retourner par là bas 1
mais non villa gardien non tu n'auras
jamais va te faire cache-toi buteur
ils jouent ce bâtard
regardez bien ces félins moustachu à
l'esv atteignent 20 cuisiner des pâtes
oh là là là là il va nous crie il va le
voir en direct
et bien ce que l affaire au coucou non
non non pas tant par le moustachu
olalalala a pas mal tes chaussures la mi
temps malév atteignent l'âge mais on va
jamais s'en sortir quoi
oui vatan je suis à gauche là bas on est
très très chaud aux fesses à très très
mauvaise la wii donc ok donc c'est bon
il s'en va [ __ ] doit trouver une vie
sorti un sale gardien
c'est bon
d'accord bon
bah hockey simple c'est une mauvaise
idée d'aller là bas on va quand même pas
de moustache est enlevée
[ __ ] j'ai tellement peur tu as un jeu
pourri la ouate à sac
vous l'avez vu oh la vache
on va passer par la nuit non mais qui a
vu en asie le cieux c'est bizarre quoi
même le moustachu devrait espère
devancer revient pour se cacher ici bas
et c'est cette porte ouverte voilà comme
ça au mois ci nous chassons peut se
cacher [ __ ] il est juste derrière là
bas il faut suivre vu ses ouailles et la
sortie tétouan espèces de sangliers
morts des gages à l'arrivée je vous
promets qu'il arrive il y avait une
vieille vague lahej et j'ai pas rêver
[ __ ] regard des locaux
je suis sûr que la sortie avait jugé à
cette porte
aux anneaux va jamais arrivé [ __ ]
petit ellipsa mais comme par hasard quoi
comme par hasard il vient vers moi quoi
mais regardez le corps à l'état fit et
panzani maintenant tu viens au lit super
et puis tant pis je l'espère
on peut y aller et où là il est juste et
à la porte il fait son vieux mec mais
cache toi oh [ __ ] voilà je crois m'en
allais m et il revient à mai mais ce mec
mais [ __ ] aller ça y est
allez casse toi là monsieur stage pu
aller [ __ ] j'ai bien fait de pas
sortir
il nous aurait déchiré et ces gens là là
bas après c'est pas dépendant ni cuisine
mais c'est f s un bon on fait quoi je
suis sûr que les sortir et là bas on va
être obligé de passer devant lui tu veux
pas te barrer tech pas dégagé comment on
fait c'est là que vous y allez oh la la
le caca on va tenter de manip de ouf les
gens
ouaf au [ __ ] mais [ __ ] mais c'est
pas possible et j'ai envie de faire un
run énorme vers la table this is sparta
c'est bon c'est bon c'est bon c'est
bourgeoisie il va se casser
on est bien là dessous il fait chaud la
température est de 2 degrés s'est décrit
il va revenir à un moment c'est obligé
[ __ ] faut passer par là là à à aller
saluer ce qu'est ce qu'il fait là
qu'est-ce qu'il fait le monsieur à
l'aller revient et dès qu'il va dans
l'autre salle on se casse pendant ce
temps des tas de gens s'amusent dans la
cour de récréation je vais pas faire du
bruit pour la tuerie qui se casse
puisque là vous pouvez être sûr que
c'est juif cette porte
il est derrière c'est sûr et certain du
coup je me suis bien dessus bonbons qui
souffre et un boisé on va le tenter
au jeu des vues ouvert à l'eau à souhait
tout pervers attend là bas y'a personne
n'y a personne
voilà là allez dégage là elle va pas me
lâcher un il veut pas me laisser
tranquille quoi tu veux pas de dégager
il est là là on a vu son tee-shirt à
travers le mur je vous promets un spa du
mytho lots aux airs il fait trop peur ce
mec
vas-y on va y aller la halle et eau pure
on se fait prendre
ou c'est wata ouais tu vas pas vu tu
m'as pas vu ça tu m'as pas vu tu veux tu
vas pas vu tu ne verras pas tu verras
jamais tu vas pas vu
mais l'époque est là lui mais c'est pour
ça c'est pour ça que je vais perdre il
est buggé lui voulait pas lui courait
dans le mur on ferait plaisir cette cour
est dans le bureau et vous allez voir
que regarder en face de la porte de la
sortie que je peux m'en voler comme un
oiseau dans l'air il ya eu un bug [ __ ]
on est ce qu'on soit un petit kit bat
façon autant permissive maintenant allez
allez enfin piqué oui c'est moi masi
bonjour toi tu es en plein de bugs
moustachu ya pas un truc sous lequel se
cache et obtient et redit il était bleu
dans le mieux regarder on peut lui faire
un bisou sur la main ça n'est pas rien
quoi quoi
mais quelle est cette arme vous avez
vous déjà vu cette discrimination que je
suis propre
il a traversé le mur est elle pour
mettre sa main dans d'immenses personnes
sur le visage pour me mettre une
seringue dans les antilles
là